Tyrion Lannister son of Tywin brother to
jaime and cersei Kingslayer [ __ ] lover
former master of coin former hand of the
king and current escaped convict is the
best character in Game of Thrones hands
down we put together some of his best
and most badass moments in preparation
for what promises to be an even more
badass season 6 but most of us when
faced with a big angry man who wants to
stab us over and over our only reaction
would be bowel related not sofa Tyrion
who always seems to have a quip at the
ready even if it doesn't always make the
situation any better
I am Tyrion son of Tywin of Clan
Lannister how would you like to die
Tyrion son of Tywin in my own bed at the
age of 80 with a bellyful of wine and a
girl's mouth around my [ __ ]
some of Tyrians best sauce is reserved
for his dear sweet sister Cersei which
quite frankly she deserves after her
years of torturing Tyrion but his best
moment with Cersei is this backhanded
compliment that sums up their troubled
sibling relationship you love your
children it's your one redeeming quality
that in your cheekbones stocks love
their children as well and we have two
of them one one Arya little animal she
disappeared disappeared
what then a puff of smoke we had three
Starks to trade you chopped one's head
off and let another escape father would
be furious must be odd for you
to be the disappointing child if only
Freud was still alive and able to
witness and diagnosed Aryans daddy
issues
maybe Tywin Lannister would still be
alive and not rotting on the potty but
he isn't and he didn't even have a TV so
here we are past the TV we'll go back to
my chambers and speak with some dignity
I concur back there she's in there are
you afraid of a dead [ __ ] you shot me
you'll know sir mine I am your son I
have always been your son
in the books
Tyrion bears the evidence of the Battle
of Blackwater as a huge disfiguring
facial scar that takes off most of his
nose in the TV series that kept it a
little simpler presumably to spare Peter
Dinklage decades in the makeup chair
nevertheless the Battle of Blackwater
still defines his character in the
latest series his wit intelligence and
ability to monologue make it one of the
best speeches in Game of Thrones
don't fight for honor don't [ __ ] glory
don't fight for riches because he won't
get anything this is your city Stannis
means to sack that's your gate he's
ramming he gets in it will be your
houses he burns go gold he steals your
women he will rape
there's our brave men knocking at our
door
let's go kill them
given that Tyrion killed his own father
and repeatedly insulted his sister it's
hardly surprising that he wasn't the
best uncle to his eldest and shittiest
nephew Joffrey but we all loved the bits
where Joffrey got even a smidge of what
he deserved and we could stand the
wailing of women one word and I hit you
again I'm telling mother oh go tell her
but first you will get to Lord and Lady
stark and you will fall on your knees in
front of them and tell them how very
sorry you are that you are at their
service and that all your prayers are
with them do you understand you can't do
you understand
tyrians never been the most pious of
guys as he says in the books if I could
pray with my [ __ ] I'd be much more
religious during a conversation with
Varys he was also about as religious as
he is testicular ly blessed he discusses
the kind of religion he might respect
Lord of Light wants his enemies burned
the drowned God wants them drowned why
are the gods such vicious whereas the
God of tits and wine Tyrion much like a
stand-up comedian is at his best when
he's on stage with a captive audience at
the Eyrie when he's accused of various
crimes by lady Liza in a fun game of pin
the murder on the IMP
he confesses but it's not quite the
confession they want when I was 10 I
stuffed my uncle's boots with goatshit
when confronted with my crime I blamed a
squire poor boy was flogged and I
escaped justice when I was 12 I milked
my eel into a pot of turtle steam my
frog the one-eyed snake skinned my
sausage I made the bald man cry into the
turtle stew which I do believe my sister
ate at least I hope she did I once
brought a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel what happened next
so those are my favorite badass Tyrion
moments from the show so far but I'd
love to know what you guys think you can
let me know in the comments what your
favorite Tyrion quips slaps and speeches
are well you can come find me on Twitter
and how not to draw if you want to find
out more about Game of Thrones you can
check out our new show
gamespot of Thrones which you can find
on youtube comm forward slash GameSpot
or on GameSpot calm thanks for watching
and if you ever having a tough time
remember Tyrians advice everything's
better with some wine in the belly I
prefer tea myself
you